all right we are down to the final four
in our pizza bracket challenge and we
want to give you a look at all the
remaining restaurants you can see the
bracket there it's naked city lucinos
giordanos and
dom demarcos out of the west side of
town in boca park and joining us this
morning live from don demarco's albert
scalia from don demarco's here in town
and albert good morning i hope i didn't
completely destroy your name i apologize
if i did but good morning to you how you
doing
i'm doing fine and welcome to don
demarco's we're not in boca park we're
at 97.85 west charleston on the corner
of charleston and huawei
well tell us about uh your pizza you
mentioned you're in the final four dom
demarco is certainly well known here in
the valley uh the pizza is outstanding
uh show us what you got there
well here you go
here's one of our
pizzas about don demarco's it's all
about quality in fact i don't know if
you could see the shirt i'm wearing now
it's our namesake dom demarco he passed
away two weeks ago in brooklyn at the
age of 85. he was the godfather of new
york style pizza an innovator and a
legend in a pizza business oh my
goodness and i spent three years working
i spent three years working with dom
demarco on avenue j in east 15th street
in the midwood section of brooklyn
learning all his recipes
and we're very proud to be here in las
vegas we take a lot of pride in our
pizza it's all about the quality and the
passion here at dom de marcos what a
beautiful tribute to him albert i have
to ask you what what is the secret to
making this pizza so outstanding
is it
an ingredient is it extra love is it the
namesake
well here's what it is
it's passion
it's a desire for perfection and quality
and it's using the best available
ingredients and knowing how to use them
put together the right recipe and i
learned all this from don demarco
and it shows everything that pizza looks
outstanding i know it's breakfast time
right now albert but my goodness that
pizza looks delightful so uh good luck
to you here in our little mouth is
watering our little good luck to you
here in this bracket challenger the
pizza there's outstanding good to see
you again this morning and i appreciate
the time so new york style pizza albert
thank you so much we appreciate you
thank you all right